-Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
You made it.
Thank you very much.
Thanks for tuning in.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys, as the war
rages on in Ukraine,
former President Trump
said that he's surprised
Putin invaded Ukraine
and that Putin's changed.
[ Laughter ]
Trump went on to say,
"This is not the man
I fell in love with."
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Trump talks about Putin
like he's his nephew
who started vaping.
"Everything was fine,
then one day..."
That's right.
Trump is surprised,
which is kind of what happens
when you flush
four years of intelligence
briefings down the toilet.
[ Laughter ]
You guys hear about this?
The CDC just lowered the COVID
risk level for cruise ships
from high to moderate.
However, the risk of getting
salmonella from the chicken
is still pretty much guaranteed.
[ Laughter ]
I guess this announcement is for
all two people who book cruises
and listen to the CDC.
It's like,
"CDC says we shouldn't."
"There's a waterslide."
"Let's book it. Let's go."
Some business news.
It's a little controversial,
but Chipotle is gonna start
using a robot
to make their tortilla chips.
Yeah, and they're
calling it Chippy.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. They also have a robot
to clean the bathroom,
but we can't say
his name on TV.
-Oh, hey!
[ Rimshot ]
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, somehow Chipotle can
build a chip-making robot
but can't make a cardboard bowl
that doesn't leak bean juice.
You know what I'm saying?
Isn't that interesting?
[ Laughter ]
Get this --
nearly 4 million bottles
of Airborne
immune support gummies
have been recalled after people
reported eye injuries
from the cap popping off.
[ Laughter ]
Apparently, when they said
"airborne," they meant the cap.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Airborne's trying to spin it.
They're like,
"Well, you're not complaining
about your cold anymore,
are you?"
"No, I guess you're right.
Yeah, you're right."
[ Laughter ]
Some TV news --
last night, did anyone see
the finale of "The Bachelor"?
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was a crazy, crazy ending.
No spoilers here,
but they did make a big
announcement about who the next
Bachelorette will be.
Watch this.
-Now, look, I already told you
it's not Gabby.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
And it's also not Rachel.
It's Gabby and Rachel!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
Wow!
Two Bachelorettes, yeah.
If you think it's weird dating
two girls at the same time,
then you've never watched
an episode of "The Bachelor."
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Inflation is so bad,
it's even raising
the number of Bachelorettes.
It's interesting.
-Oh.
-Oh, this is interesting.
I saw that Spotify has agreed
to sponsor
Barcelona's biggest soccer club,
so now their name and logo
will appear on the team's jersey
and stadium.
It's good news for Spotify,
but you can already tell
they're having an influence
on the way games are broadcast.
Take a look at this.
-We've seen that move before.
Beautiful pass.
And Ferran Torres has the shot.
J-o-o-o-o-o-o-oe...
Rogan!
New episodes every day,
1:00 p.m., here on Spotify.
-Interesting.
[ Laughter ]
Joe Rogan.
-Joe Rogan.
[ Applause ]
And, finally,
a man in the U.K. was arrested
after he led police
on a 35-mile chase.
And when they finally
pulled him over,
he showed them a license
from Legoland.
[ Laughter ]
And he'd still be locked up
if he didn't have
that "Monopoly"
"Get out of jail free" card.
We have a great show.